les travaux du centre-ville de maurepas
avance depuis octobre dernier des
dizaines d'ouvriers travaillent pour
redonner une nouvelle jeunesse au
quartier l'ancien sol goudronné laisser
place à du granit et un nouvel escalier
a déjà été construit c'est surtout de
redonner de la visibilité de commerce de
proximité parce que quand on arrive dans
le centre-ville de maurepas on s'est
aperçu qu'on avait un gros bouchon
qu'avait été construit dans les années
80 dans sa seconde phase avec vous savez
le bâtiment du kiosque fleury qui lui a
été détruit ou le le commerce de
proximité de des fleurs a été déplacé un
peu plus loin donc de retrouver de la
visibilité mais aussi de retravailler
les ambiances des éclairages de
replanter des arbres des plantes
bref de retrouver à centre-ville plus
qualitatif plus commerçants également au
total 64 commerces de la ville sont
concernés par ces travaux ce traiteur
est installé depuis 13 ans dans le
centre ville
c'était des travaux qui était nécessaire
ça c'est vrai mais bon un peu trop long
en délais c'est surtout ça nous pour le
commerce est un petit peu compliqué mais
bon autrement pour moi je sais c'est que
du positif je suppose que ça peut
qu'embellir maurepas coût total de
l'opération 1,4 million d'euros financé
en partie par la région et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la commune
investit quand elle 800000 euros dans le
projet ces huit cent mille euros qui
sont injectés pour l'avenir parce que là
on est vraiment sur une première phase
de restructuration du centre-ville parce
que évidemment il y aura d'autres
fassent dans les années qui viennent
parce qu'on se projette aussi à long
terme et cet investissement vraiment à
long terme et on en avait bien besoin
la livraison définitive de ce centre
ville flambant neuf est programmée pour
le mois de juillet